[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend gestern war noch die frage
wie europa und deutschland die neue
corona variante draußen halten könnte
heute abend ist sie drin einige wenige
fälle erst das ist aber keine beruhigung
die ganze pandemie ging hierzulande ja
mit einer handvoll infektion los bei
einem bayerisch internationalen
autozulieferer vor fast zwei jahren und
jetzt wird unter hochdruck untersucht
was diese omikron variante noch
gefährlicher machen könnte als delta die
verantwortlichen in regierung und
instituten haben erst mal nicht mehr
anzubieten als vorher nur noch
dringender masken abstand kontakt
beschränkungen impfung nur mehr denn je
ines trams berichtet
flughafen johannesburg schlange stehen
unsicherheit wien uhr gehts weiter
schuld ist nikon die neue wohl
aggressivere corona virus variante die
in südafrika entdeckt wurde viele flüge
nach europa gestrichen die reisenden
erwartet in deutschland 14 tage
quarantäne
wir haben
morgens davon erfahren dass es eine
virusvariante gibt
mittags
haben wir dann versucht umzubuchen mit
der fonds und abends wurden alle flüge
gecancelt kurzfristig wir wollen nach
belgien mit stopp in frankfurt aber wir
wissen nicht ob wir es nach belgien
schaffen
gemessen an den virus varianten better
und delta ist omikron offenbar viel
ansteckender binnen weniger tage ist der
anteil von omikron an den infektionen in
südafrika auf mehr als 90 prozent
gestiegen offen inwiefern die impfstoffe
schützen bei dieser variante omikron
können wir das abschließend nicht sagen
es gibt noch keine laborexperimente die
laufen weltweit auf hochtouren also die
booster bleiben wichtig gerade auch bei
den varianten bieten einen schutz nun
ist die omikron variante in deutschland
gelandet mit zwei südafrika rückkehrern
die am mittwoch über münchen eingereist
sind es wurden dann bei anderen die
weiterhin hier bei uns bleiben
quarantäne anordnungen ausgesprochen es
wurden die gesundheitsämter mit
einbezogen es wurden die daten erhoben
so dass wir aus unserer sicht alles
getan haben was rechtlich möglich war
derweil brummt der weihnachtsmarkt und
das weihnachtsgeschäft da wo es noch
erlaubt ist wie hier in berlin doch wie
lange noch rufe nach kontakt
beschränkungen ja einem lockdown werden
heute lauter dieser neue virus trieb
omikron macht uns sehr sehr große sorge
und da müssen wir in die lage versetzt
werden sehr kurzfristig zu handeln
sollte sich herausstellen dass omikron
wirklich sich radikal schnell verteilt
dann brauchen wir dringend eine
grundlage dafür um harte maßnahmen zu
treffen an dem wir dann nicht mehr
vorbeikommen eine deutliche anklage
gegen eine unentschlossene politik auch
von der leopoldina die
gelehrtengesellschaft fordert sofort
kontakte zu beschränken auch die von
geimpften und genießen versuche jetzt
die vierte welle zu brechen haben dich
funktioniert und eigentlich fordern wir
massive kontakt beschränkungen also wenn
man ehrlich ist ein lockdown für etwa
drei wochen den mann massiv putzen
sollte zum boostern die regionalen
unterschiede sind euch sehr groß dass es
eine politische entscheidung aber
sinnvoll wäre eigentlich flächendeckend
die wissenschaftler kritisieren scharf
das flächendeckende schließungen mit der
neuen ampel koalition nicht mehr möglich
sein sollen der künftige kanzler unter
druck hält sich heute alles offen wir
werden alle weiteren schritte tun die
sich noch als richtig erweisen es gibt
nichts was nicht in betracht gezogen
werden kann derweil werden weiterhin
patienten verlegt von den hot spots im
süden und osten des landes um dort die
intensivstationen zu entlasten ein
sicheres zeichen dafür
der handlungsbedarf ist groß
die zahlen sind deutlich der trend
ungebrochen
das rkw meldet heute
67.000
125 neue infektionen sind gut
3200 mehr als vergangenen samstag
innerhalb von 24 stunden sind 300 und 3
todesfälle dazu gekommen die sieben tage
incidents liegt nun bei 4
144,3 in diesen tagen wird einem klar
was für ein glück es ist vielleicht
erstmal war in einem land zu leben wo
kompetente hilfe und alle ressourcen
modernster medizin nur ein notruf
entfernt bereitstehen diese garantie
gibt es so nicht mehr mit jedem tag mit
jedem sprung der täglichen statistik
weniger viele die sonst in größter not
professionelle hilfe leisten können
erleben jetzt wie es ist kein ausweg
mehr zu wissen eine reportage von eva
schildern
der erste notruf ein schlaganfall
ihre schicht hat gerade begonnen doch
die meisten intensivbetten in stuttgart
sind schon belegt ein großteil der
häuser doch probleme schon wieder auf
mit den intensivbetten hat das ist
natürlich
beruhigend
notarzt sein heißt in diesen tagen vor
allem um betten zittern kliniken
anbetteln dabei aber trotzdem den
patienten möglichst schnell gerecht
werden der mann ist instabil leidet
möglicherweise noch an einer inneren
blutung
im klinikum stuttgart wahrte dr
alexander kron auf die nächste corona
patientin abwehren was geht ist die
devise kommen eigentlich täglich an die
grenzen und jetzt war es letzte woche so
dass wir die letzte herz-lungen-maschine
verbaut haben und da denkt man schon
früh was mache ich mit dem nächsten 40
jährigen von ihrem vater die 28-jährige
kobe patientin ringt um luft
also schon erhebliche lung befall zu
erwarten ich würde mal mit rechnen dass
wir sie auf jeden fall aufnehmen sie ist
gottseidank zumindest einmal geimpft es
hilft einfach jetzt kommt notarzt
rüdiger schwager mit dem schlaganfall
patienten der mann schwebt in
lebensgefahr muss auf die
intensivstation
nur dass es nur dann anstrengend weil
man weiß dass man natürlich nicht
unbedingt gern gesehen ist wenn man im
nächsten patienten reindrückt obwohl
samberg anschlag sind aber gut gefüllt
es muss gemacht werden
der nächste einsatz und parallel alarm
im schockraum die ärzte mussten einen
mann reanimieren jetzt wird er beatmet
und der nächste herzinfarkt rollt an es
ist ein arbeiten am limit das zehrt
wir haben alle die schnauze voll davon
aber so langsam wirds halt auch schon
schwierig sich wieder zu motivieren die
nächste welle wieder zu nehmen und
wieder zu gucken was man alles noch an
lösungen für die probleme finden kann
das geht schon an die substanz sei
irgendwo platz schaffen wie lange geht
das noch es droht träsch ich hab da hat
jeder angst vor weil es auch eine
ethische frage ist ein stückweit
reagieren wir ja schon auch unterbewusst
ja also wo man sich manchmal den gros
war das gut denn jetzt nach hause zu
lassen das ist ja schon so eine
vorstufe der triage alle betten belegt
und ausfliegen ist im akutfall keine
option wenn ich jetzt einen patienten
habe der braucht jetzt eine versorgung
dann habe ich eine stunde zeit das
irgendwie zu organisieren und kann ich
ein flugzeug irgendeiner hamburg
besorgen rüdiger schwager übergibt an
den nächsten notarzt ohne dass ein
notfall passieren darf in dieser nacht
im großraum stuttgart
es ist nicht nur für eine
nachrichtenredaktion schwierig in so
einer lage rüberzukommen in den
politischen regelbetrieb ohne zu
schleudern dieser alltag geht halt
weiter fast als gäbe es die krise nicht
die alle beschäftigt da muss halt einer
erstmal ins kanzleramt und hoffentlich
bald verantwortungsvoll handeln die
akademie leopoldina zentrale des
sachverstands verlangt heute in klaren
deutschen setzen handeln sofort jetzt
davor steht aber unter anderem noch ein
spd-parteitag nächste woche vor dem
wiederum stand heute die begegnung des
kommenden kanzlers mit seinen jusos das
sind die die ihn weder als
parteivorsitzende noch als
kanzlerkandidaten haben wollten aber
jetzt brauchen beide seiten die andere
um dorthin zu kommen wohin sie alle
wollen an die macht andreas künast
beobachtet diesen tanz die geschichte
von olaf scholz und den jusos ist sehr
lang und sehr wechselhaft sie waren
ziemlich erbitterte feinde als olaf
scholz spd chef werden wollte sie sind
ziemlich beste freunde seid olaf scholz
kann da werden will die geschichte von
scholz und den jusos ist die der groko
die er wollte und sie bekriegten ein
kampf nachdem die gemeinsame lust auf
die ampel fast unwirklich wirkt herzlich
den aktuellen vizekanzler nicht mehr
lange aber noch und in zukünftigen
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
urlaub schon jetzt herzlich willkommen
der libero love kommt mit einer klaren
vorstellung zum bundeskongress nach
frankfurt dass es nie mehr so wird wie
es war
ja zunächst mal stelle ich mir vor dass
ihr
begeistert seit über das
regierungshandeln
[Musik]
die jusos haben allen grund zum lachen
heute sie sind so stark wie noch nie
stark vertreten in der
bundestagsfraktion stark genug der
politik der vergangenen jahre den kampf
anzusagen und wir stehen nicht hilflos
vor diesem zeitgeist sondern wir stehen
hier weil wir ihn verändern werden und
wir haben jetzt so viele machtmittel
darf in der hand wie nie zuvor die
geschichte von fast kanzler scholz und
den jusos ist eine geschichte
wechselnder macht sie beginnt mit noch
kanzler schmidt und dem widerstand gegen
den nato doppelbeschluss
das bedeutet dass ein sowjetischer
computerfehler
[Musik]
genommen und genossen es hat schon sie
auch der zeitung gestanden dass die usa
gesehen haben gesehen haben auf ihren
computern dass sie angegriffen werden
und sie haben fast der halbe stunde
gebraucht um herauszufinden dass das
nicht stimmt ist ja irgendwie
fernsehbilder aufgetaucht bin wie ich so
ausgesehen habe und was ich so gesagt
habe da habe ich mir doch was sind das
für eine aber egal auch die jugend von
heute nervt die regierung von morgen zu
wenig spd im koalitionsvertrag zu wenig
schutz für arbeitslose wer nicht bereit
ist die regelsätze anzuheben der soll
auch nicht von der überwindung von hartz
4 reden zu wenig schutz für mieter
lieber urlaub was ist aus dem moratorium
geworden wo es hin zu wenig schutz vor
abschiebung ich hab jetzt lange überlegt
ob ich das irgendwie diplomatisch
formulieren kann oder als konstruktive
kritik aber ich finde das einfach nur
scheiße scholz zählt alles auf was die
spd als erfolg verbucht mindestlohn
wohnungsbau und bitte die jusos ihre
kritik nicht auf die drei ampel parteien
zu richten was soll ja was gemeinsames
gelingen und deshalb glaube ich mach das
schon noch sinn dass man sich mehr mit
der cdu beschäftigt mit den alternativen
die dort formuliert werden als mit denen
mit denen wir hier diesen aufbruch jetzt
gemeinsam wagen wollen nur ein kleiner
tipp von mir die geschichte von olaf
scholz und den jusos ist sehr lang und
sehr wechselhaft und man ahnt es
irgendwie sie ist noch nicht zu ende
die nachrichten fügen sich fugenlos an
auch die grüne jugend hat über den
koalitionsvertrag beraten und ihren
mitgliedern die zustimmung empfohlen
trotz vorbehalten vor allem in der
sozial- und klimapolitik es gebe keine
ampel euphorie so die
nachwuchsorganisation der grünen aber
dieser koalitionsvertrag eröffnet ein
erstes fenster für verbesserungen in
einer urabstimmung müssen die 125.000
grünen-mitglieder bis zum 6 dezember den
koalitionsvertrag mit einfacher mehrheit
annehmen
im tarifstreit des öffentlichen dienstes
der länder zeichnet sich auch in der
dritten verhandlungsrunde keine einigung
ab 5 prozent mehr geld monatlich aber
mindestens 150 euro mehr fordern die
gewerkschaft verdi und der beamtenbund
für die rund 800.000 angestellten
das sei überhöht sowie arbeitgeber die
jetzt aber über zahlen reden wollen ob
bis morgen eine einigung erzielt werden
kann ist offen
die chinesische armee hat nach taiwan
militärübungen durchgeführt see und
luftstreitkräfte hätten ihre
kampfbereitschaft erprobt erklärte ein
chinesischer armeesprecher die übungen
erfolgten auf einen besuch von us
abgeordneten in taiwan die dem land ihre
solidarität zugesichert hatten taiwan
ist eines der grössten konfliktthemen
zwischen den usa und china peking
betrachtet taiwan als abtrünnige provinz
heute vor 60 jahren wurde das
schlafmittel contergan vom markt
genommen und zum ersten mal hat sich nun
ein mitglied der eigentümerfamilie des
herstellers grünenthal an die opfer
gewendet per video barth michael wirtz
im namen seiner ganzen familie um
entschuldigung und richtete persönliche
worte an betroffene die in bad nauheim
über ihre situation berieten von etwa
5.000 contergan geschädigten leben noch
2400 mit erheblichen beeinträchtigungen
mit denen sie auf die welt gekommen
waren nachdem ihre mutter in der manger
schafft kontakte angenommen hatten
und hier nun die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
sie lauten 7 14 15 29 36 37 superzahl 3
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text das wetter bringt zum
ersten advent einen hauch wind regen und
schneeschauer zum teil bis ins flachland
gibt es morgen vor allem im westen und
süden die sonne kommt nur im norden
durch sonst überwiegen die wolken bei
minus 1 bis plus 5 grad so bleibt es zum
wochenbeginn dienstag und mittwoch kommt
schnee auf der aber in regen übergeht
mit schweren sturmböen ist zu rechnen
bei vier bis zehn grad
und alles um sport jetzt gleich im
sportstudio mit sven voss wir wünschen
ihnen einen schönen ersten advent und
sehen uns dann am abend hoffentlich hier
bis dann
[Musik]